نعم الارقام في ازدياد والاعداد في ازدياد
والكثافه تتعاظم هنا في مدينه بورسودان
الباصات السفريه تاتي تباعا الى هذه
المدينه تقل عشرات الاسر ومئات الاسر التي
تصل من العاصمه الخرطوم
بوسط السودان تصل من مدينه عطبره
بشمال السودان تصل ايضا من مدينه مدينه
واد مدني بوسط السودان كل هذه المدن الان
ياتي منها المغادرون ياتي منها الذين
يرغبون في مغادره السودان في عمليه
الاجلاء الكبرى عبر هذا المنفذ البحري
وعبر المنفذ الجوي ايضا في مدينه بورسودان
عشرات كما ذكرنا بل مئات من الاسر ما زالت
تاتي الى هذه المدينه اعداد كبيره منهم
الان في طريقهم ايضا الى مدينه
بورسودان سنحاول ان نقترب اكثر
لننعكس لكم عبر هذه الصوره الحيه التفاصيل
استقبال الذين يرغبون في مغادره السودان
وما يقدم من خدمات والبعد الشعبي والبعد
الاجتماعي الذي
يتعاطى ايجابا مع هذه الاعداد التي تشهدها
مدينه بورسودان يمكن لاول مره هذه النسب
من العائلات ومن الاسر التي تصل الى مدينه
هذه هي مجموعه من شباب مدينه الان تعمل
على تقديم مياه الشرب النقيه لمئات الاسر
الموجوده داخل مركز حصر وتنسيق
وتوفيق اوضاع من يريدون مغادره السودان
خلال الساعات المقبله الشرطه السودانيه
ايضا تعمل على تامين وعلى حمايه هذا
المركز وتنسيق الجهود بين الشرطه وبين
اداره الجوازات ايضا كما نتابع قيادات
الجيش السوداني ايضا تعمل بتناغم مع مختلف
القيادات وضع مختلف الوحدات الفنيه
والاداريه في هذا المركز سنقترب اكثر
بصوره داخل هذا المركز
لتن وتوفيق اوضاع مئات الاسر النسبه
الاكبر هنا في هذا المركزيه للسوريين
الذين وصلوا بعدد يقدر باربعه الاف سوري
يطلبون مغادره السودان ويطلبون
الاجلاء خلال الساعات المقبله تحدثنا الى
كثير منهم العقبه الرئيس الان تتمثل في
عدم تحديد ميقات الزماني للمغادره تم
تسليم الجوازات من قبلهم للجهات المعنيه
وهم الان ينتظرون دورهم في مغادره
بورسودان الى عدد من الوجهات منها المملكه
العربيه السعوديه منها سوريا لكن اوضاعهم
تظل كما تتابعون الان عشرات الاسر تحت هذه
الخيم استظلوا بالشمس خلال الساعات
الماضيه عديده الجهات الخيريه والحكومه
هنا ايضا تعمل على توفير الامكانيات
المتاحه بحسب ما تمتلك من امكانيات على ان
تمضي الامور كما هي ايضا عدد من المواطنين
ايضا يقدمون الدعم والسند ويوجهون ايضا
السوريين بان هنالك مناطق ايواء وهكذا
ينادون عليهم كما استمع الان الى احد
مواطنين مدينه بورسودان هو الان يوجه عدد
يوجه عدد من السوريين واليمنيين بان هنالك
عدد من مناطق الايواء لو اعطيتنا فكره
عامه يحدث وما هو الدعم الذي يقدم من
قبلكم انتم كلجنه بسم الله الحمد لله
والصلاه والسلام على رسول الله
نحن الان مسؤولين كلجنا من الترحيل حسن
الان عندنا حفلاتنا جاهزه عندنا المناطق
روايه جاهزه باذن الله تعالى بالنادي
بالناس على اساس انه السوريين والناس
اللي لسه اجرعاتهم مكتمله عندنا داخليتين
مجهزه من كل شيء حتى اذا الجهاد في الجهات
خيريه انه نكون في مواقع هذا الدعم الشعبي
ام رسمي من هيئه الامم البحريه وحتى
الحفلات الموجوده من هيئه البحريه نحن
بنقوم بالتنسيق مع اللجنه العليا هنا
بنقومنا حول الناس الى مناطق بتاع تيواء
امنه فيها حمامات فيها بس بنفرز الرجال من
النساء لكن التحدي كبير بالنسبه لكم تحدي
كبير جدا بالنسبه لنا ولكن الناس يفهموا
وينظموا يعني يعني
بيقول للناس انه يعني
مثلا الزول كبير مع العفش اما الناس
الثانيين انه النساء عملنا لهم موقع محدد
الرجال عملناها لموقع محدد نحن كهيئه مهند
البحريه ان شاء الله جاهزين وان ارحل
الناس لمناطق الايواء ونرجعهم من مناطق
اللواء ان شاء الله ليعملوا اجراءاتهم
وبرضو هنرحلنا ان شاء الله للبواخر ويعود
الى بلد هل عملتم على حصر النسب للاسر
للشباب للشيوخ والله نحن حتى الان الحصر
صعب حقيقه يعني
ان احنا حاسد عملنا حاجه حاليا قبل يومين
مع الاخوان الصينيين وشلناهم من مناطق
الهواء وطوالي الى البواخر الحمد لله وكان
الشغل مشى بطريقه سلسه جدا الشغل هنا
التنظيم على اساس انه الناس يعني يعرفوا
وقت 200 نحن من مناطق اليابان ان شاء الله
نحن جاهزين على كله وجزاكم الله خير وبارك
الله فيكم هذا هو مصوت الجهد الذي يقدم
ازاي هذه الازمه المتواصله وصول المئات
الى مدينه بورسودان وعشرات الحالات الحرجه
ايضا لاحظناها للنساء في حالات متعسره بعض
الاطفال بعض الشيوخ كل هذه المشاهد وكل
هذه الصور هي ان عكاسات لازمه حدثت قبل 14
يوم وما زالت تبعاتها وتاثيراتها
وتداعياتها مستمره حتى الان نزار يعني اذا
استطعت ان تاخذ يعني حديث احد يعني هؤلاء
الذين ينتظرون في ميناء بورتسودان الحديث
عن الرحله من الخرطوم الى بورتسودان كيف
كانت ايضا المصاعب التي واجهوها اثناء
بقائهم حتى في الخرطوم اذا استطعت
نعم سنحاول ذلك وسنستمع ايضا الى بعض
الافادات وبعض القصص حول الطريقه التي وصل
بها السوريون ووصل بها الاردنيون ووصل بها
اليمنيون الى هذه المدينه ساحاول ان نقترب
اكثر نحاول نحاول ان نقترب اكثر نحن الان
على الهواء مباشره كيف كانت الرحله من
الخرطوم الى هذه المدينه بورسودان والله
صاحبه كثير صعبه شديد وفي ناس معاهم عيال
واولاد مشكله
يعني كتير صعبه يعني في عالم 16 ساعه 17
ساعه من الخرطوم الى مدينه بورسودان نعم
17 ساعه
يعني وعذاب كتير والحمد لله اجينا لهون ما
قصروا معنا ونحن عم نقترح على الهم في
مدارس هنا اذا بتفتح نقعد فيها بس لبين ما
الله ييسر امورنا عرفت كيف لانه هو
المطلوب هذا المطلوب انه في مدارس قريبه
فيها حمامات يعني الناس بتسهل الامور شوي
بس العادات كبيره اعداد كثير اسا انا في
ناس معهم عيال في ناس معاهم نسوان مشاكل
يعني مشكله وما حدا عم يسالها من الاخير
يعني انا حابب احكي كلمه بس ما تقطعوها
بتمنى منكم ما قطعوا نحن على الهواء الان
انتم على الهوى يعني احنا حاسين حالنا
طرشه غنم
هيك يعني دايرين حدا يجي بس يسيرنا بالعصا
يعني انت الان تطالب بالسفاره يعني حدا
يتكلم فينا بس في ناس معه في ناس معهم
نسوان يعني اي واحد بيعني هالكلام اذا بحب
يكون اخته ومرته شرفه وهيك متشرط بالشوارع
الجماعه ما قصروا معنا والله شالونا
وساعدونا كتير بس في حد يعني
المفروض بس يعني والله لو طرش غنمه هيك
اذا هي الرساله واضحه نعم هي الرساله
واضحه للسوريين لليمنيين لعديد الجاليات
التي تطالب الان بتوفيق اوضاعها باسرع مما
يكون نسبه للوضع الحرج الذي تعيشه الاسر
في هذه المنطقه هما الان يستعدون لمغادره
شرق السودان الى عدد من الدول في المنطقه
والاقليم
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات